Es ist soweit!
Die ersten detaillierten Aufnahmen von dem
weitest entfernten je aus der Nähe fotografierten
Objekt.
Und genau diese Aufnahmen wird es jetzt zu
sehen geben.
Wie sieht ein solches Objekt im Kuipergürtel,
dem Asteroidengürtel rund um unser Sonnensystem.
6,4 Milliarden Kilometer entfernt.
Eine absolute Weltpremiere.
Jetzt bei Clixoom Science & Fiction
Jetzt ist es raus.
Die große Frage ist was ist das für ein
seltsames Projekt ist das.
Wir hatten es gestern berichtet.
Beim Vorziehen an Sternen machte das Objekt
etwas sehr seltsames.
Es ist rund 30 Kilometer lang und hat eine
sehr seltsame Form.
Das wurde 2017 und 2018 festgestellt.
Mit zahlreichen Teleskopen wurde dabei die
Flugbahn von Ultima Thule beobachtet oder
wie die korrekte Bezeichnung ist 2014MU69.
Er ist allerdings soweit von der Sonne entfernt,
dass er kein Licht reflektiert oder nur ganz
ganz wenig.
Allerdings verdeckt er immer wieder Sterne
und dabei wurde festgestellt, dass sie nicht
einfach hell und wieder dunkel werden, sonder
abgedunkelt werden, dann wieder etwas heller
werden, dann wieder etwas dunkler und dann
erst wieder endgültig hell.
Ultima Thule muss also eine Form wie zwei
aneinanderhängende Kugeln oder etwas ähnliches
haben.
Und jetzt ist es das verrückte herausgekommen.
Die damals vermutete Form ist exakt die echte.
Es ist das erste Mal, dass ein Objekt entdeckt
wurde, dass aus solch zwei exakten Kugeln
besteht.
Und das erklärt auch ein Paradoxon von Ultima
Thule.
Als sich New Horizons nämlich jetzt näherte
stellte die Sonde etwas sehr seltsames fest.
Ultima Thule machte etwas unerwartetes.
Statt wie bei unregelmäßigen Objekten Licht
unregelmäßig zu reflektieren, passierte
das nicht Doch New Horizons konnte das Rätsel
heute noch besser lösen.
Ultima Thule dreht sich sehr speziell und
rotiert wie ein Propeller, zeigt uns also
immer dieselbe Seite.
Und das es zwei Kugeln sind, ist die Reflektion
immer gleich.
Damit ist das erste Rätsel jetzt noch besser
gelöst.
Es ist also in mancher Hinsicht eine Sensation.
Ein solches Objekt in einer solchen Entfernung
wurde noch nie aus der Nähe beobachtet.
Und es hat eine absolut spektakuläre Form.
Und es gibt schon eine Theorie, wie das Objekt
entstanden sein könnte.
Zahlreiche kleine eishaltige Objekte könnten
zuerst umeinander gekreist sein und am Ende
gab es die beiden großen Objekte, die dann
“aufeinandergefallen” sind.
Die Gravitation der beiden Objekte, obwohl
sie mit ein paar Kilometern sehr kelin sind,
reicht aus, um sie aneinander zu binden.
Genauso, das Forschungsteam, kann man sich
die Entstehung der ersten Planeten vorstellen.
Ultima Thule ist damit quasi eine Zeitmaschine
in den Anfang unseres Sonnensystems.
Ein absoluter Glücksfall für die Forschung
ist dieses spektakuläre Objekt.
In der Pressekonferenz, die soeben zuende
gegangen ist hieß es “Das wird unser Wissen
revolutionieren!”
Und heute gibt es noch eine spektakuläre
Videopremiere auf unserem englischen Kanal:
“Fuel from CO2 - New innovative technology
makes gasoline climate freindly!”
Hier draufklicke und anschauen und natürlich
abonnieren!
See you soon, stay tuned!